le 22 juillet dernier 5 mois après le
début du conflit qui a fait Moscou
parvenait à un accord sur l'exportation
des céréales ukrainiennes en mer Noire
un texte signé sous la houlette des
Nations Unies de la Turquie qui prévoit
la mise en place de couloirs sécurisé
dans cette zone pour la circulation des
navires marchands mais avec des
conditions strictes imposées par la
Russie c'est cargo doivent être
inspectés au départ et en direction des
portes Ukrainiens sous le contrôle d'un
centre de coordination conjoint basé sur
le Bosphore à Istanbul objectif
débloquer rapidement les millions de
tonnes de céréales entassées dans les
silos du crâne après des mois de blocus
maritime russe mais depuis la situation
s'étant venimée Vladimir Poutine
exigeant davantage de garantie notamment
la protection de la flotte russe dans ce
corridor humanitaire
l'inquiétude principale de la Russie
c'est que les navires entrants ne soient
pas respecter et qu'il soit utilisé pour
de la contrebande d'armes c'est pour
cette raison que Moscou insiste pour
mener ses propres inspections en mer
même lorsqu'elles ont déjà été faites à
Istanbul
autre point sur lesquels Moscou insiste
le déblocage des exportations des
produits agricoles russes et la
livraison de céréales en priorité aux
régions les plus exposées à une crise
alimentaire les pays africains
jusqu'ici toute région confondue 10
millions de tonnes de céréales
ukrainiennes ont pu être exportées
principalement depuis trois ports ce
dossés
50% des exportations depuis la mer Noire
donc ils ont une importance capitale ces
trois derniers mois ils ont transporté
environ 3 millions de tonnes par mois et
c'est beaucoup plus que ce qu'on a vu
avant l'accord mais cela reste très peu
par rapport à ce qui sort habituellement
de ses ports en cette période de l'année
l'Ukraine espère désormais exporter plus
de céréales depuis d'autres ports alors
que l'accord arrive à échéance le 19
novembre prochain